oh you're gonna play mind games we
didn't know we can use the this tool for
this game right this game we don't need
the aura strap for this so you can stick
your restaurant in your hand right now
you should feel vibration yes I think
it's actually the number of vibrations
you're feeling you're gonna feel the
diced role that I have I'm gonna feel
the dice you all that you have and
psychologically we have to try to
basically I want to have the higher role
yeah and but I feel your number so if I
feel like it took 16 in here or 12 or
something I'm like oh wow Peter has a
really high by 100 role again so I try
to fake you out and make you reroll
could you can try and okay so this is
like something complex my name so so
you're able to reroll a couple of times
so afterwards you only want me to
re-roll if mine is really high but I
could also try to fake you out right so
you know what he's thinking you don't
know what anybody's thinking speak for
yourself never underestimate so what's
your once you're confident your number
what you'll do is you'll so you'll roll
you'll you'll flip your kind of dice
over in the cup and then once you're
happy with your roll you'll lift your
hand up to basically lock in your your
roll so it'll make sense well as we play
okay so there are some different rules
in the middle here too so if you feel it
too I have snake on us and that's
actually if the best score 99 so you
might be like oh Cory has two but really
I just shake yours you icon and somebody
come roll can you go too high that's
what I'm wondering about the purpose of
making yuuri roll if I know that you
have a high score if I roll I could get
higher low it's not kidding yeah it's
yeah it's just gonna be a different
number yeah so
so now you're feeling my number I'm
feeling yours vibrations to check your
opponents dice roll say something about
your opponents dice roll definitely so
just lift up oh man just lift your hand
up right now yeah if you want you can
just just because my first time I would
be honest with you ready whip your cups
up all the same time if you re room your
opponent will be able to feel your new
total you're good he's good at this I'm
just hmm chorus you ready oh you're
enrolled to feel your new total it's
really good
well I'm good all right let's do it
I see what comes when I lift up lift up
eight you had like an eleven by the way
your first roll use the vibrations to
check your opponent's dice roll this one
is also really good you're really high
and I'm good I'm sad
yeah you said am sad okay cuz you were
like waiting to count I'm pretty sure
the reaction was like oh you're trying
today it's okay that was your strategy I
actually was trying to roll there I
should I realize when I blink the last
time last time last game here
High Roller to check your opponent's
dice roll oh you're totally this is like
your highest you said that ever you
actually you actually have Snake Eyes
there's no need this is your lowest we
got you up snake eyes this is your
lowest one okay when you're ready yep
snake eyes so just flip it over
yeah yeah dang it for sure I did not
think you're gonna listen
[Music]